Ist Wasser vielleicht DER neue Treibstoff
für Raumschiffe?
Ein russisches Start-up-Unternehmen jedenfalls
will genau diese Technologie etablieren.
Als “dreimal so effizient wie chemische
Triebwerke” und als “Schlüssel für die
Erforschung des Sonnensystems” beschreiben
die Gründer ihre Idee.
Schon 2019 soll ein erstes Testgerät ins
All gebracht werden.
Hammer!
Die Infos jetzt in Clixoom Science & Fiction,
hier gibt es täglich faszinierende Wissenschaftsvideos,
abonniert den Kanal, nur dann verpasst ihr
nichts. herzlich willkommen!
Wasser gilt für viele Weltraumforscher als
hochinteressanter Rohstoff, weil es in Wasserstoff
und Sauerstoff aufgespalten werden kann.
Und klar ist: Sauerstoff ist für uns Menschen
wichtig und Wasserstoff könnte als Treibstoff
dienen.
Auf der Erde gilt Wasserstoff schon seit längerer
Zeit als ein heißer Kandidat für eine emissionsfreie
Zukunft des Verbrennungsmotors.
Solch ein Motor könnte vor allem in Verkehrsmitteln
eingesetzt werden, in denen Elektroantriebe
nicht mehr klar kommen - beispielsweise bei
Schiffen, Flugzeugen oder auch in LKW.
Im Rhein-Main-Gebiet beispielsweise sollen
Dieselloks schon Ende 2022 durch Personenzüge
mit Wasserstoffantrieb ersetzt werden.
Sie werden emissionsfrei durch eine Brennstoffzelle
angetrieben: Dort reagiert Sauerstoff mit
Wasserstoff und Strom wird erzeugt.
Im Gegensatz zu Batterien kann hier in Minuten
getankt werden.
Auch das russische Start-up “Momentus”
hat in diesem Bereich große Pläne - allerdings
bezogen auf den Weltraum: Demnach sollen Raumschiffe
schon in naher Zukunft mit Wasser angetrieben
werden.
Allerdings ganz anders.
Das Wasser selbst soll als Reaktionsmasse
in den Triebwerken als Antrieb genutzt werden.
Hier soll durch Stromzufuhr ein Plasma erzeugt
werden - Wasser würde stark aufgeheizt werden
dann aus einer Düse austreten und so den
Vortrieb erzeugen.
Das Konzept trägt den Namen “Thermisches
Lichtbogentriebwerk”: Es würde quasi wie
ein dauerhaft pfeifender Teekessel oder ein
Dampfkochtopf aus dem man Überdruck ablässt
funktionieren.
Heißer Wasserdampf erzeugt Rückstoß.
Einfach aber genial!
Die Vorteile der Technik: Es wird sehr schnell
ein sehr großer Schub erzeugt; größer als
mit Ionen-Triebwerken, wie sie heute schon
bei Satelliten eingesetzt werden, aber nur
relativ wenig Schub erzeugen.
Dennoch soll auch eine dauerhafte Nutzung
gewährleistet werden, um so größere Distanzen
zurückzulegen.
Zudem ist Wasser wesentlich preiswerter als
Gase wie Xenon.
Der Gründer des Unternehmens ist der russische
Ingenieur und Physiker Mikhail Kokorich und
er sieht seine Idee als zukunftsweisend.
Mit dieser Technologie könnte endlich das
gesamte Sonnensystem erforscht werden.
Dieser Antrieb könnte beispielsweise Objekte
ins Sonnensystem bringen - und das im Vergleich
zu Ionen-Antrieben mit Xenon-Gasen in nur
der Hälfte der Zeit.
Bis zu zehn Tonnen könnten so in die geostationäre
Umlaufbahn gebracht werden.
So zumindest die Angaben des russischen Start
ups.
Der Treibstoff könnte direkt vor Ort “abgebaut”
werden, denn Wasser ist an vielen Orten im
Sonnensystem zu finden.
Schon 2019 soll ein erstes Testgerät ins
All geschickt werden; dieser Prototyp namens
“Zeal” benötigt nur eine Energiezufuhr
von 30 Watt und kann nur relativ kurz zünden
180 Sekunden.
Dazu gibt es bereits einen Vertrag mit dem
europäischen Raketenstart-Anbieter “ECM
Space”, der den Prototypen auf einem Mikrosatelliten
befördern wird.
Der Erfinder Kokorich ist äußerst optimistisch,
was seine Lösung für das Antriebs-Problem
angeht: "Wenn die Transportkosten sinken,
entstehen viele Geschäftsmodelle".
Konkret denkt er an Asteroiden-Bergbau, Mondflüge
und Weltraumtourismus.
Aber natürlich könnten so auch Raumsonden
angetrieben werden, die zur weiteren Erforschung
des Weltraums dienen.
Ob überhaupt und wenn dann - wie gut - dieser
theoretische Ansatz tatsächlich in der Praxis
funktioniert, wird sich wohl auch erst dann
herausstellen.
Wenn das System wirklich Erfolg hätte, wäre
dies durchaus ein riesiger Fortschritt in
der Raumfahrt und könnte uns die Türen in
neue Welten öffnen.
Wie es mit dem Projekt weitergeht erfahrt
ihr natürlich hier bei Clixoom.
Abonniert dafür am besten auch den englischen
Kanal, dann auch da gibt es immer wieder Videopremieren.
Und hier geht es weiter mit New revolutionary
space propulsion Ja, auch die ESA macht bei
Antrieben extreme Fortschritte.
Ich freue mich auf euch auf dem englischen
Kanal.
Stay tuned, see you soon.